Levi is a lot like myself he thinks a
lot about
um you know what could happen he is a
lot he is an overthinker
um so honestly I don't know what he's
thinking I'm he's definitely probably
scared he's definitely confused
um yeah I don't know
come right and say
and he's just seeing pictures of him
here when he was on the x-fraction also
playing rugby I think he spoke to him
um honor about the 26th of October
didn't you what did he say how did he
sound
um he actually sent me a voice note
um so I messaged him after the video
came out um on Instagram
um he made a video talking about a lot
of things that he was going through
um and I messaged him the day after just
sending you know look from the family
making sure he's okay asking if he needs
any support
um and he sent me a voicemail and voice
message back just saying you know that
um he's a fighter and he's gonna keep
fighting and that he loves us
um and that he appreciates you know
everything that we've been doing for him
and
um just being there and he was just
talking about you know continuing to
fight
Suzanne um I believe he was in Ibiza
with friends and he told them who's
going to go and see some people in in
Barcelona what do we know about what
happened there
um speaking to one of his friends
um Levi contacted one of his friends
saying that he needs to get out of Ibiza
and when his friend
um spoke to him he asked why she says he
needs to get out and he was actually on
on a ferry from Ibiza going to Barcelona
um this is what his friend told me but
that's the last thing you heard from him
his friend did say that he might be able
to go out there to meet him just to meet
up with him in a couple of weeks so for
Levi to you know just keep in contact
but he hasn't heard from him either
and Suzanne um we know that he uh a
couple of years ago talked about his
sexuality
um
and we're also hearing uh in a video
that has I think since been deleted on
social media that he felt that he was
being blackmailed was there any sort of
connection between those two do you
think
I have no idea I know Levi came to see
myself last last year and we did speak
about
um his sexuality and what you know how
he felt and how he came out
um but I have no idea how that's how
that's transpired today I don't know
what's happening now I don't know what's
going on why he's gone why whether it's
anything to do with that he might be
just frightened he did say that in that
video that he he thought that his life
was in danger
um I don't know whether he's running
from something
we just don't know so that's why people
are so concerned that he hasn't
contacted anybody
and he's got such some great support I'd
have thought at least one even the
friends that he'd spoken to prior to
going that he'd speak to somebody but he
just hasn't so that's why we're
everybody's so worried
and and what's going to happen Suzanne I
mean he was last seen I think in a bar
there's some CCTV I've seen in the
papers this morning in Barcelona I mean
are you are you considering going out
there to try to help with the search or
what are you hoping to do currently not
because he's I know his mom's going out
and a couple of other people are going
out there
um to see what they can do
um
I suppose it's like finding a needle in
a haystack isn't it you don't know where
he is unless he keeps gets in contact
with somebody so we know where he is
he's safe and he's well
we're just we just don't know what's
happening so
um I'm not currently got any plans to to
go out there no no yeah no that's fair
enough
um Candice uh we know that a lot of
people watch this program
um in in Spain indeed around the world
um if if he's watching Levi you know he
might feel Under Pressure he might think
oh you know I've been missing for a week
now I don't know how I can reach out to
the family and tell them that I'm okay
what would you want to say to him
I just want to let Levi know that
obviously he's loved by everyone
um
you know um I just want to also let him
know that we're here to support him and
I just want him to come home he's loved
and he's missed by everyone Levi is an
amazing person
um and I just want to thank everybody
who has been you know searching for Levi
I've had so many messages talking about
how they've been attending bars
attending public places as well with
Flyers of Levi's face
um so Levi we are looking for you
then we just want you to come home
and I thought a final thought from um
stepmom or a foster mum today what would
you say to him
Levi um you've got such support here
from family and
some some of your friends as well lots
of support you you know there's no
reasons to stay away come home get the
support you need
and go home to your mum and she's so
she's so um worried about you
everybody's worried
you know just get in touch just let us
know that you're safe at least so that
we can we can help you and get you the
help that you need